notons abonnés on est au nord-est de
philadelphie au lendemain d'une nuit
d'émeutes
quelques personnes sont venus ici et ont
dégradé les commerces vous pouvez le
voir désormais placardé avec ses
planches de bois des vitrines ont été
cassées ici s'agit d'un magasin qui vend
de l'alcool quelques bouteilles ont été
dérobées mais c'est surtout des dégâts
matériels qui sont a recensé environ
trois commerces sont concernés par ces
dégradations évidemment c'est un
préjudice très important pour eux en
pleine période de pandémie de kobe 19
enfin toute nue devant tueur toutes les
portes ont été cassées tous les
commerces ici ont été vandalisés c'est
terrible on est maintenant dans le
centre de philadelphie est ici aussi
certains commerçants ont décidé de se
barricader comme vous pouvez le voir en
installant également des planches de
bois
ils veulent absolument éviter que leurs
commerces se soient dégradées en marge
des manifestations qui se déroulent
depuis le début de la semaine ici à
philadelphie et qui ont contraint le
maire de la ville a décrété un
couvre-feu
vous l'aurez mois
[Musique]
des manifestations qui ont été
déclenchées par la mort d'un homme noir
tué par la police en début de semaine
alors les forces de l'ordre affirment
qu'ils étaient en possession d'un
couteau qui ne voulait pas lâcher
une enquête a été ouverte par les
autorités est évidemment les deux
candidats à la présidentielle américaine
suivent de très près cette affaire il
faut dire que philadelphie se trouve
dans l'état de pennsylvanie qui est un
état clé pour cette élection de la halle
trump affirme qu'il suit la situation et
il a pris la parole
il en a aussi profité pour attaquer ses
rivaux démocrates des chefs des groupes
c'est d'un groupe qu'il soutient il ne
veut pas les condamner j'ai vu ça il ne
veut pas les condamner ils font les
condamnés il faut être fort on ne peut
pas avoir un tel chaos
le problème avec jo c'est qu'il parle
mais n'agit pas il faut des actions
on ne peut pas laisser ça arrive et je
suis allé à l'école dans cette ville
j'adore la ville de philadelphie on ne
peut pas laisser ça arrivait dans un
endroit comme philadelphie
c'est affaire de philadelphie illustre
que les antagonismes demeurent entre
certains habitants et les forces de
police à quelques jours du scrutin de la
présidentielle les divisions sont
toujours ancrés aux états unis et ce
après plusieurs mois de manifestations
notamment la suite de la mort de joe
hart lane
en attendant ici à philadelphie la
police locale va être épaulé par des
unités de la garde nationale de
pennsylvanie déployé spécialement pour
l'occasion et pour éviter tout
débordement lors des prochaines
manifestations